tu es accordé hier mais elle est en
plein redressement judiciaire 281
employés attendent d'être fixés sur leur
sort est donc de savoir quelle sera leur
éventuel repreneur mais le débat s'est
déplacé donc sur le terrain politique
l'état est partie prenante dans ces neuf
dans cette affaire par le biais de
vallourec actionnaires d'ascq ovale ce
matin et xavier bertrand président de la
région haute france est dans l air se
montrait sommé le gouvernement de d'agir
sur cette question en l'écoutant c'est
une chance si clairement l'état qui est
actionnaire de vallourec demande à
vallourec de continuer comme ils le font
depuis des années de continuer à acheter
les aciers qui sortent de cette usine
d'ascq ovale la question c'est ce que la
france n stratégie industrielle
est-ce qu'on veut uniquement des start
up il faut des start up mais moi je ne
veux pas uniquement des start up
je vais aussi gardé de l'industrie des
causes l'année des cols bleus n'ont pas
dans un instant tout ça mais on complète
avec la réaction bruno le maire bruno le
maire -ministre de l'économie dans le
temps est d'autant plus ferme que ça
marche et je sus prêt à ce que l'état
met un euro d'investissement sur ask
ovale dès lors qu'un euro
d'investissement privé aura été trouvé
pour un projet qui soit durable
oui c'est nouveau mais je vous disais
antichar goût je ne lâche rien mais je
viens rien c'est se creuse elle le
gouvernement et l'état peuvent
clairement faire plus on peut toujours
en théorie faire plus un mètre de large
en prendre enfin leur capitaine une
entreprise et que l'état peut on devenir
l'actionnaire après la question c'est
celle de l'utilité de ces fonds publics
utilisés comme ça c'est l'argent des dd
ça va ça reste l'argent des français
moi je dirais plutôt si on savait que
c'était la bonne pluie que ça serait
plus 40 ans sarkofrance on a
régulièrement fait ça c'est toujours une
histoire
florence l'impression c'est toujours
même scénario et
et rien en fait on agit par coup par
coup mais d'argent comme ça sur le
soukous d'émotion et il se passe rien et
la production industrielle française
décroît a décru va pas retrouver encore
tout à fait son niveau de 2008
on a perdu un million d'emplois dans
l'industrie et voilà tandis que
l'allemagne qui est quand même pas connu
pour ses bacs où elle a vu sa production
augmenter donc c'est pas la bonne
stratégie vivent aujourd'hui c'est quoi
la solution la sidérurgie française est
moribonde
est ce qu'elle peut être maintenue sous
perfusion je suis d'accord avec vous que
c'est le même scénario qui se reproduit
régulièrement et c'est le scénario
classique de l'état ne peut rien et il
faut délocaliser et l'emploi industriels
par quitte la france
on n'a pas un double effet six zones de
pink sociale et en même temps des
capacités de délocalisation qu'offrent
les dispositions l'union européenne
oui pour une fois je suis d'accord et
xavier bertrand puisque lui défend sa
région il est donc il défend des gens en
chair en os concrets des français qui
est pas leur travail
ne retrouvant pas d'autres parce qu'on
aura pas de start-up là bas et tous ces
gens là comme toutes les autres
entreprises comme gms dans la
souterraine souffre d'un système où on
fait croire qu'il a un repreneur mais
qui en fait sert à fermer l'entreprise
ans par petits bouts en épuisant
complètement les syndicalistes et les
gens sur place jusqu'à la fermeture
définitive
c'est tragique et je crois que la france
peut faire un peu mieux et l'histoire de
monsieur le maire de 1 euro pour c'était
ça c'était ce qui a été proposé à
l'époque d'alstom donc ce n'était pas la
droite c'était c'était monbourquette
pour alstom et puis puis alors qu'un
euro avaient été trouvés dans le privé
finalement l'état a pas mis un euro pour
1 euro investi on a tout vendu à déjà et
rixes monsieur macro l'état finalement
sert à quoi quand il est actionnaire je
demande c'est une démonstration que
l'économie mixte ça sert pas à grand
chose parce que finalement les l'état
est un peu l'otage des entreprises dans
lesquelles est actionnaire et il prend
pas forcément les bonnes décisions et
l'économique ça marche pas enfin on voit
bien que c'est ces sociétés comme air
france notamment où l'état est présent
le fait que l'état soit actionnaire ça
ne sert pas à grand chose
plus globalement sur le sur le cas de de
cette usine de saint saulve
c'est vrai qu'on a vit toujours sous le
coup de l'émotion en fait il est
important de considérer le secteur de
l'acier où on en est là scier les
niveaux de prix de l'acier dans le monde
aujourd'hui baisse la demande baisse les
chinois ont modernisé leurs usines
ce qui fait que nos usines à nous mais
voilà elles sont elles sont pas
compétitives mais mais en revanche je
suis assez d'accord qu'il fallait lancer
un grand plan de réindustrialisation de
la france et il faut s'appuyer sur une
start-up contrairement à ce que pense
monsieur bertrand yves le disais il ya
eu florange alstom ça va être un
sparadrap pour le pour le gouvernement
non mais je pense que on manque d'une
stratégie industrielle depuis très
longtemps et les stratégies de pailhères
elle doit être imaginé penser au niveau
de l'europe et problème c'est que
l'europe
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait l'europe l'europe
elle cherche à réguler le marché en
interne à faire en sorte que on se fasse
pas de concurrence entre nous qui ait
pas de concurrence déloyale entre nous
mais elle ne nous protège pas deux des
concurrents étrangers ça c'est la
première des choses
il est anormal par exemple pendant
l'acier l'asti n'est pas un secteur mort
c'est pas vrai bassil a de quoi on
souffre aujourd'hui on souffre du fait
qu' il y ait aussi des sanctions
imposées par les états unis par monsieur
trump donc l'acier n'est pas
complètement c'est pas un secteur qui
est en voie de disparition
ça c'est la première des choses la
deuxième des choses c'est que pourtant
moi je suis un libéral mais convaincu et
vaccinés eh bien regardez ce qui se
passe aux etats unis quand il ya un
secteur qui est en danger
quand un secteur qui est défaillant mais
le premier qui arrive c'est l'état
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec general
motors general motors était c'est un
libéral qui vous parle general motors
était complètement en faillite
à l'issue de la crise de la crise
financière de 2008
l'état est venu à son secours ils ont
fait le ménage serre qu'ils ont fait le
ménage vous coupez le personnel je crois
qu'il ya la main d'oeuvre est divisé par
trois mais généralement tôt c'est un
gros party je pense que ce qui se passe
c'est qu'il faut que l'état soit là les
tailles régulateur l'état peut aider ces
sons sa fonction mais l'état ne doit pas
si ce sens il ya un instant iv ces
signaux dizaine un sens on a vu dans les
expériences passées parce qu'on sait pas
mais la tendance a servi à rien mais non
mais il était pourquoi à vis de l'argent
dans les banques mais aussi d'ailleurs
cécile il faut pas que ce soit le héros
ni on a envie de l'argent c'est quartet
pas l'état qui doit qui doit gérer
évidemment qu'il doit laisser ça à des
opérateurs mais les temps ont emménagé
en algérie pour mettre de l'argent dans
de l'acier n'est pas un secteur morts
si on continue à dire ça c'est mort ça
c'est mort ça c'est mort et que d'un
autre côté on pleure parce qu'on n'a
plus d'industrie la difficulté d'aller
intolérance quelque peu la difficulté je
pensais trouver de savoir que si
l'entreprise est viable ou pas c'est un
secteur general motors est une crise à
particuliers en 2008 on savait qu'ils
aient des actifs cadets tva qu'on
pouvait la renoncer après on a souvent
mis de l'argent dans des entreprises où
il n'y avait pas d'avenir en fait tout
le reste et industriels étaient trop
vieux ou il y avait ou des productions
qui était une victime tout cas le plus
absurde c'est quand même aussi ont
fabriqué par alstom à belfort des tgv
pour rouler sur des lignes on en arrive
à des trucs dingues industriels dont on
sait qu'on s'est quand même mais pour le
coup j'ai plutôt libérés annoncent et
fin de tendance libérale que finalement
la régulation celle qui se fait mieux
c'est par le besoin des consommateurs et
pas celle qui envoie le stimulus des
produits correct les gens ont envie
d'avoir ces oiseaux on sait pas se
battre on sait pas se battre mais
pourquoi les annonces des annonces sont
dans un système libéral
ils savent se bat décision aussitôt
promis bientôt
tissu français n'est pas complètement
inadaptés il ya l'exemple de toyota qui
fabrique les usines toyota japonais
toyota qui fabrique des yaris à
valenciennes c'est un vrai succès il yal
usine bombardier à valenciennes un
groupe canadien qui fabrique des
voitures proposent pour des trains il ya
des milliers d'employés de d'ouvriers
dans cette usine que je vais avoir la
chance de visiter bientôt d'ailleurs
pour ça que j'en parle
après il ya aussi il ya évidemment le
politique de l'état il ya aussi la
politique du dialogue social j'ai visité
une chrysler à detroit il ya quelques
années des trois était une ville fantôme
il ya une industrie automobile qui est
reparti à détroit roth entendront notre
presque parce que les syndicats ont
accepté à un moment un certain nombre de
choses et notamment des réductions de
salaire pendant un certain temps ils ont
retrouvé depuis leur pouvoir d'achat
mais c'est un bel exemple quand même où
tout le monde fait des sacrifices mais
après c'est une politique à long terme
c'est un politique de choix de
civilisation et autant dans les années
80 avant quand on ferme et 6 du rgi
j'avais 20 ans la sidérurgie mamba
autant ces morts autant s'en libérer
laisser les pays en voie de
développement reprendre cette activité
autant aujourd'hui je pense que l' usine
doit faire partie doit refaire partie du
paysage français et revalorisation
d'être à emmanuel enfin voilà il ya tout
ça est ce que l'absence des chiffres
étonnants s'échauffent dans le
raisonnement c'est on dit on veut
l'industrie donc faux de l'état pourquoi
notamment pas de là à l'autre de l'âge
est-ce que le problème c'est l'union
européenne le problème c'est l'union
européenne où on a un marché entièrement
ouvert et imagine mais je vous dis aimez
les allemands ils s'abonnent européenne
mais ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont fait le
problème
non ils ont fait un programme qui
essaient de bismarck de la mitteleuropa
ils ont fait une intégration
géopolitiques et économiques de l'ordre
de l'est et europe centrale et ils
peuvent embaucher
grâce à eau au libéralisme de la
commission européenne
des gens à 0 75 centimes qui viennent
d'ukraine qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire
malheureusement c'est comme ça dans un
système dans un marché qui a entièrement
ouvert un salarié français qui sera un
minimum à 1100 150
laurence toujours des salariés fois plus
cher car selon elle très bien mais n'ont
annoncé 2000 au même niveau
un ouvrier d'accord ça qu'il soit 0,75
sauf que il ya 11 ans dans l'entreprise
allemande
ce sont des usines d'assemblage avec les
ouvriers allemands qui sont payés à plus
de 2000 3500 même euros mais les sous
traitants et justement les aciéries qui
composent les bm et les opel sont faits
dans ce port tour qu'il contrôle où vous
avez maintenant avec le traité de libre
échange entre l'union européenne et
l'ukraine qui roule depuis un an des
gens 45 millions de personnes où le
salaire moyen est à 250 euros et
vallourec ne peuvent pas rivaliser
points et donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a
systématiquement ce dumping social qui a
organisé et l'état peut faire si il fait
comme les américains et trump ou les
autres c'est quand il ya du coton qui
est menacée par les africains boom
il faut un becquet arrière qui font du
protectionnisme est donc content cela
rien comprendre que ça qu'il faut que ça
soit fait parce que au niveau
renouvellement pêche
mais oui mais vous savez le peuvent pas
parce qu'on a eu un commissaire européen
à l'industrie qui étaient britanniques
qui étaient anti européen pendant des
années et des années et qui nous ne va
pas pour autant mener avec ne nous a pas
protégés
ça a quand même été avec un des
problèmes majeurs de l'union européenne
qui ne nous a pas protégés des marchés
extérieurs
il s'est plutôt occupé de savoir à
l'intérieur si on ne se fait pas et pas
de la concurrence déloyale c'est ça qui
met l'europe en crever de ça parce que
l'europe se regardent de l'intérieur et
essaye de se préserver valent pas de
préserver de préserver des équilibres
internes au lieu de s'occuper de ce qui
se passe à l'extérieur quelques réponses
à notre question twitter qui est l état
doit tout faire pour éviter la fermeture
de dasque ovale alors vous êtes 57% à
dire que vous dites
la majorité a estimé que oui les toits
doit se et pour que l'état intervienne
parmi vos réactions jeu j'en donne
quelques unes johan l'état ne peut rien
faire ce sont les actionnaires qui
décide donc plutôt le contraire
nicole nous dit les politiques ont
laissé partir ou fermée presque toutes
les industries maintenant il pourrait
sauver l'aciérie point d'interrogation
un peu tard dit elle il y aura toujours
on ne va pas tout nationaliser l'état
d'autres obligations régaliennes
l'eau c'est au marché de décider pas à
l'état l'eau l'ol au surnom notre
internaute nicole encore quand l'état se
mêle de ces industries ça se termine
toujours mal à la fin comme il a un
petit peu expliqué cécile je vous
propose quand même d'avancer sur ce
thème passionnant on l'a vu alors c'est
un peu un incident mais c'est xavier
bertrand ce matin toujours interviewé
sur rtl qui parlait à ce moment-là de la
rémunération des patrons des pdg du cac
et il avait une proposition un petit peu
iconoclaste on écoute si la part
variable des patrons était pas lié
seulement aux résultats financiers
métailié d'une façon ou d'une autre à
l'emploi l'emploi est absent absent de
tout élément de rémunération mais beria
trouvez ça normal vous cécile c'est
démagogique
bonne idée occasions mais on peut
considérer effectivement qu'il ya une
envolée des salaires des patrons depuis
20 ans pour considérer que savions à
moyenne pour un peu quand même
alors on est sur un marché en voie de 6
passes et que sur 1 ils sont sereins sur
un petit périmètre ils se connaissent
quand même tous plus ou moins entre eux
donc ya pas vraiment de concurrence et
tout ça ça pour c'est tout ça tous les
salaires à la hausse et comme les
actionnaires qui des votes année dérange
pas en fait alors l'idée d'un excellent
mondial dans les rêves sur l'emploi et
sur les résultats en matière de données
dans les ascensions non non non un
système où il n'y a pas de
contre-pouvoirs français c est ce que
c'est un projet de civilisation
si effectivement l'action des dirigeants
d'entreprise doit rémunérer au maximum
les actionnaires et les financiers bah
oui il y aura moins d'emplois mais ici
il y a une part sociale mais on a parlé
de l'époque des tic de l'entreprise mais
juste l'intérêt le simple intérêt pour
ses concitoyens pour ceux qui
travaillent sur le même territoire
ben oui ça serait bien que soit le
bonheur dans le bonheur d'entreposage
mélenchon là ils jouent évidemment il
est président d'une région ça se passe
pas très bien il doit faire du social
donc il adapte son discours sur le fond
moi je trouve c'est pas une bonne idée
je souhaite que les patrons soient le
mieux payé possible si leurs salariés
sont le mieux payé est possible aussi et
puis les deux propositions pour que
l'écart ne soit pas alors ça c'est sûr
positionne la france a sauvé je suis
complètement contre alors là non entre
mille dix ou vingt selon d'or mais s'il
voulait c'est toujours la même chose on
n'arrivera jamais parce que je suis
contre ces sociétés de kara caractère
socialisante ce qu'il faut c'est que les
patrons une conscience
tout est dans la conscience un système
libéral ne peut pas marcher s'il n'y a
pas de conscience dispense de bannir et
moi donc ce trentenaire heures de
contre-pouvoir patron qui est payé c'est
un problème d'éducation
si le citoyenneté d'éducation ce n'est
pas non c'est à dire que le pape oui les
gens vous soyez pas tronqué une
conscience et qui paye mieux ou bien il
sera mis en concurrence immédiatement
par un autre qui n'aura pas de
conscience et cristallise depuis que
c'est bien sûr c'est là évidemment c'est
aussi vous n'êtes pas de régulation des
états est à la tête d'une entreprise et
man a très bien et que vous êtes
outrageusement bien payés c'est qu'il ya
un problème il ya un problème de
conscience du patron le capitalisme
quelques soirées règles qui ont des
tabliers
elles seront contournées donc même si on
adopte interdite d'êta qui est une bonne
chose qui permet tout le monde de jouer
dans un quartier afin de sauter en
conscience je rejoins que ce que disais
à l'instant absolument
après il ya je trouve qu'on devrait
développer davantage encore
l'actionnariat salarié mais c'est vrai
que la gauche trouvait pendant très
longtemps je me souviens d'une
expression de françois hollande qu'on a
interrogé là-dessus il ya quelques
années il disait je trouve ça un peu
aliénant à 22 67 c'est dommage parce
qu'on en aurait on devrait évoquer bien
davantage
il faut que les noms mais il faut les
que le salarié partage la pression va
pouvoir je pense qu'il n'y a pas
forcément que l'état laisse apparaître
la controverse a peut être le les
syndicalistes comme ils étaient plus
forts avant avant avant les années 90
quand il y avait le mur de berlin qui
avait la menace communiste tout le monde
avait la trouille
tout le monde se tenait bah voilà c'est
ça un contre-pouvoir un contre
maintenant aujourd'hui y'a plus doux
mais c'est vrai il ya plus ben oui y'a
pas une menace est attendu ça l'a fait
émerger karim ghellab le sais ce que je
dis ah non ce que je veux dire c'est que
le système a besoin pour le camp libéral
je crois aux contre-pouvoirs contre s'il
n'y a pas de contre pouvoir lui-même
lui-même le syndicat des patronats la
sidérurgie s'est illustré quand même des
décennies dans l'achat et la mise en
difficulté des syndicalistes qui
résistaient un peu trop alors n'oublions
pas que les patrons du cac 40 s'est dit
elle et le problème c'est que c'est eux
qui font l'image des patrons en france
alors qu'il ya dix ans et qui ils
abusent le maire a répondu tout à la
question il c'était celle sur le toit le
politique est ce qu'il va être vraiment
ça va lui coller à la peau cette
histoire de la capacité finalement ce
que ma couille du real et comme bien des
précédents malavoy y était allé en 2016
comme ministre il avait dit vous pouvez
dormir sur vos deux oreilles bien sûr
mais c'est bien sûr mais vous savez il
ya un précédent qui a coûté très cher à
lionel jospin quand il avait dit l'état
ne peut pas tout on était en
l'occurrence dans le secteur automobile
je crois que c'était à valenciennes
c'était justement avant que toyota
n'arrive et en 1900 à 2000 il avait 10
août 1999 il avait dit l'état ne peut
pas tout bas l'état ne peut pas tout
tous les français qui sont plutôt assez
un colbertiste et 2 jacobins et ben ils
l'ont renvoyé à ses chères études
donc dire en france